[Applause]
four hours outside the westminster
bubble and here problems for the prime
minister are clearly cutting through
the day began with an electoral
earthquake
a constituency that's been tory blue for
its entire history today fell into the
hands of the liberal democrats
almost 200 miles away from westminster
but not far enough to ignore allegations
of sleaze and scandal that have dogged
politicians in westminster for weeks
i think it's because of all the scandal
that's just gone on on television i
believe that
the people voted
as a
as an anti-conservative vote
but how far does this new mood extend
across the nation the prime minister
spent the morning at a hospital in his
own constituency having to admit what
went on in number 10 last year
distracted from the issues that matter
do you acknowledge that that vote
against the conservative party was
because of you
clearly the voting uh in north
shropshire is a is a very disappointing
result and
i i
totally understand people's frustrations
i i hear
what the the voters are saying in north
shropshire and uh in all humility i've
got to
accept uh that that verdict yes sam
you trying to change the sleaze rules in
favor of you and your colleagues which
triggered the by-election which caused
this defeat yeah do you accept hand up
hands up responsibility for that yeah i
i do it comes into the overall category
of politics of
politicians talking about
ourselves and
those issues
and seeming
to be focused on those
issues at the expense of the things that
really matter to people and so i think
my job is to
get over what we're we're doing more
effectively
boris johnson has an exceptional and
unusual ability to connect with people
whether it's in north shropshire or here
in his adopted political home of
uxbridge in west london people think
he's a rascal but on their side they
rarely feel indifferent towards our
prime minister
but what if the by-election shows that
those strongly held views are reversing
in direction
even in places elsewhere like here
in his own constituency
it is those downing street and whitehall
parties and how he's handled that issue
that really seems to have changed minds
what do you think of boris johnson at
the moment i still think he he doesn't
really know what what he's what he's
doing or what he wants you know but have
you voted for him in the past i have but
i don't think i will be
next time comes around what was that
what was the thing that had changed your
mind really i don't know i think it was
all the
the partying lies and
and um you know what what what what went
on i wish it would be a bit more honest
and more decisive
the signals it gives to everybody is so
confusing at the moment we don't know
whether we are coming or going
we need a new leader would you vote for
both strokes again
i don't think so
not no more since the party it threw me
and
it just took all the trust away
boris johnson has held this seat as an
mp for six years but his own mps on his
own benches say to hold office as prime
minister he now needs to move on from
season scandal
over the last couple of months there
have been some absolute missteps no
prime minister wants to have the story
um about him and what may or may not
have gone on at number 10. i mean
he can't afford for that to continue
but that's exactly what happened tonight
cabinet secretary simon case the man
appointed to investigate parties in
downing street in whitehall last year
has admitted he too went to one now
tarnished tonight he was taken off
running the probe
in his place is sue gray a former ethics
chief who takes no prisoners that will
rattle some of those already implicated
i do believe
that the investigation that sue gray is
going to be leading up there's evidence
there they need to carry that
investigation out very swiftly to
restore the public trust and then hand
over that evidence to the police
troubles mount but it's in places like
this where the public must judge
do not underestimate rebellions that
start in market towns like this one